let's just bring you some breaking uh
news now the brexit minister lord frost
has resigned tonight uh we're gonna go
straight to our deputy political editor
sam coats
sam what more can you tell us about this
bombshell news
lord frost david frost may not be a
household name but his departure tonight
is going to be extremely significant for
boris johnson now lord frost submitted
his resignation a couple of weeks ago in
a letter to boris johnson goes in the
new year he says it's on good terms but
the departure of the man who was the
architect of brexit for the prime
minister whose primary aim is to get
brexit done will be another blow for
downing street after a tricky
week we understand that the reason lord
frost is saying he is going is because
he is unhappy with the direction of
government he thinks that taxes under
boris johnson are getting too high he
thinks there is too much emphasis placed
on net zero uh the plan to
get rid of uh carbon emissions from the
environment and the cost that that
places uh on the environment and as it
were the final straw we are told the
reemergence of covet regulations those
regulations uh that
uh uh
that we've only heard about coming back
because of omicron in the last few weeks
why does this matter well first of all
lord frost will be echoing a lot of the
concerns that many tories particularly
those on the right of the party have
secondly it matters because lord frost
was seen as a very important figure
particularly to brexiteers as a
guarantor that boris johnson will
continue to pursue the kind of hard
brexit that they wanted to see we're in
the middle of a massive negotiation over
northern ireland
and that northern ireland protocol david
frost i suspect very unhappy with
briefings from parts of government uh
that his priority which is to scrap any
role for european courts in the
oversight of northern ireland no longer
a big factor uh friends of david frost
not saying that that's a massive deal in
the resignation but it's hard to escape
that that's probably likely to be quite
uh a big factor lord frost has worked
alongside boris johnson for years during
the wilderness years where he was
alongside
where he was out of government during
theresa may's time
and supported him as the mayan who was
the architect of his brexit plan from
day one in government this will unnerve
a large part of the brexit supporting
right of the party it's also a sign of
the instability across the whole of the
regime
and i think tonight uh mps will be
reeling at the news of a man that they
thought that was integral
to boris johnson and a guarantor of a
particular direction for the
conservative party uh will be going in
the new year
and sam it's not the first time we hear
uh whispers rumors that uh david frost
might resign it was thought when it came
before that it might have been a
negotiating tactic to say that he might
resign over the uh northern ireland
protocol have there been do you think uh
presumably there must have been thoughts
about his successor
so that's absolutely right it was only
in january that lord frost threatened to
quit as then a non-ministerial role as
an advisor to boris johnson because
michael gove seemed to be doing a lot of
the heavy lifting when it came to
brexit once we'd left the transition
period uh he threatened to leave and was
actually handed a cabinet job his
current job at that point uh in effect
upgrading as a result of threatening to
walk
we do know thou that uh uh we do
understand from two allies of david
frost and one government source that he
has gone uh that he has submitted his
resignation and will leave in the new
year um some allies suggest that this is
on good terms but they also say this is
likely to have ramifications for the
conservative party replacing him is
going to be very hard because of the
unique background that he brought to
that job he has become the expert in
negotiations with the eu he is the face
that the eu know it isn't immediately
obvious um that there is a light for
like replacement and every mp every
conservative will be watching to see
that whether or not there is somebody
sort of equally hard line put in that
job because david frost was seen at the
more hard-line end
of brexit negotiators or whether
boris johnson picks somebody a bit
softer or tries to get away without
filling the job at all that is why the
job matters because it is seen as an
indicator of the direction of boris
johnson's government some mps worry he
is going a bit soft uh on brexit the dup
very nervous about uh recent
developments on the northern ireland
protocol and this apparent softening
of the position as i say david frost not
indicating that that's the final straw
that's uh he's going uh he we understand
because of wider concerns about the
direction of government but whatever way
you cut it is very bad news for downing
street tonight